[Musique]
elle s'appelle mystery chat elle mesure
1 m 53 et aurait vécu en egypte sept
cents ans avant notre ère
elle a été retrouvée avec ces cercueils
à la fin du 19e siècle
il ya beaucoup des momies qui viennent
avec le secret mais on n'est pas certain
que ce soit le même dans les cas de
nesta budget on a à la fortune d'avoir
le sait c'est sûr que yaël qui nous
donne toutes sortes d'informations
les chercheurs ont pu déduire qu'il
s'agit d'une femme riche de 39 à 45 ans
maîtresse de maison
originaire de thèbes l'actuelle ville de
louxor nesta ou jack est l'une des 6 me
qui seront présentés dans le cadre de
l'exposition monnier égyptienne passé
retrouvé mystère dévoilé
ils ont achevé ce qu'ils voulaient
larmes encore là donc leurs normes la
présence nous amène nous aide à
comprendre les passes et comprendre
notre présent et peut-être aussi notre
futur depuis des siècles les mots me
frappent l'imaginaire on se voit on se
peut refléter sur les momies en encore
humaine comme nous sommes nous sommes
qui est là et il a traversé le temps et
l'espace
une chose que nous pouvons nous aspirons
à faire mais qui sait pas possible au
moins que en basset ferme mes fils
les avancées technologiques permettent
de révéler une foule d'informations
auparavant inaccessibles ma maman
l'exposition cris par le british museum
est présenté ici en première nord
américaine
ici les mots ni ont réussi à traverser
les âges ce n'est pas simple de leur
faire traverser l'océan six mois
un grand voyage qui permettra aux
visiteurs de se plonger dans l'egypte
antique à travers l'art et la science
ici n'est bien lexandre chartier radio
canada montréal
[Musique]